تدخل الحرب في السودان اسبوعها الرابعه
لتحدث انعكاسات متعدده على المواطنين في
كثير من انحاء الخرطوم حيث تعرضت الكثير
من الاسواق والمحال التجاريه والمنازل
للسرقه جراء الامن مع دفع المواطنين الى
البحث عن حلول لتامين احيائهم وممتلكاتهم
بانفسهم احصل
سرقه ونهب
فهنا الحله ما شاء الله رايت ناس الحله ما
شاء الله ما قصروا يعني ارتكازات ما شاء
الله على مستوى عالي فاغلبيه الناس
انهم يسرقوا الدكاكين فالناس ما شاء الله
تصدت لهم ما في دكان واحد في جريف غريب من
الحاره الاولى لحد الحاره الثانيه سرك
منطقه الجريف غرب احدى المناطق ذات
الكثافه السكانيه العاليه تجاورها محلات
تجاريه واسواق عديده تعرضت للمحاوله سرقه
ونهب من قبل اللصوص الذين استغلوا غياب
الشرطه والامن فتصدى لهم المواطلون الشرطه
ما موجوده صراحه والله صرت ما موجوده لكن
اولادنا يعني
انه يعملوا المنطقه من كل التفلات الامنيه
الوضع الامني المضطرب جعلهم يشكلون دوريات
حراسه ويجلسون لساعات طوال خشيه دخول
اللصوص للمناطق السكنيه
الحراميه كثير وكسروا الدكاكين لحد
الاولاد يخلوا النوم كل يوم كاسرين دكان
الاولاد والله قاعدين في الشعر خلوا
بيوتهم والله
بكره الصباح قاعدين في الحته دي كان في
البدايه النبي لكن اولاد الحله
واجتمعنا كلنا وامنا دوريات
الحاجه في ظل الظروف الامنيه المعقده
والواقع المتازم بصوت البنادق والاشتباكات
العسكريه ارتفع صوت الاهالي بضروره رفض
الحرب املا بعوده الامن والحياه الى
طبيعتهما
لا للحرق لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات